it wouldn't be a stretch to say that
teamwork is the lifeblood of shonen
anime in that my hero academia is no
different the show is teeming with well
great acts of teamwork and with that
being the case today we're going to be
counting down the series top 10 team
fights in my hero academia let's see
how those awesome quirks clash and
combine and needless to say
spoilers ahead you have been warned oh
wait before we get into the video i'd
like to thank today's sponsors
zen market with online shopping being
all the rage these days and the number
of anime related merchandise at an
all-time high wouldn't it be great if
there was an aggregate service which you
can use to order from
have no fear zen market is here zen
market is a japanese shopping service
that allows you to add items from a huge
selection of japanese stores and
auctions
yes even auctions too and we're not just
talking about run-of-the-mill japanese
stores too
this service allows you to order from a
lot of exclusive online retailers such
as pokemon center japan
p bandai and melon books to name a few i
mean don't you think that's just amazing
i mean my experience with the website is
that it sure is
because now i can just use one site to
pick my items instead of manually going
to different websites and going through
the whole checkout process
and you get to enjoy all that service
and a lot of promos such as cashback on
raku 10 items twice a week
with amazing customer service worldwide
shipping and compatibility with multiple
payment options such as paypal and
crypto i doubt that you're going to find
a better online market service than this
if you're interested make sure to check
out the link in the description box for
more information on the website see if
it's
your liking and start shopping now let's
get on with the video
kicking off things at number 10 is gang
orgas
invasion of the provisional hero license
exam
with his appearance and abilities that
resemble a killer whale orca
is a hero who seems very much like a
villain if you don't know him well
enough that is his imposing physique in
hypersonic waves make him a class
a threat naturally he's very convincing
as a faux villain during the exam arc
it's a given that orca will give the
students a tough fight
but in this contest we also get to see
orga's other side a nurturing figure
who's deeply invested in the next batch
of heroes and is willing to help them
reach their full potential
we see this in the way he coaxes
dodoroki and inasa
mid-battle to put aside their
differences work as a team and learn to
use their highly mismatched quirks in a
way that turns them
into a formidable attack pair since this
exam's all about teaching the students
to prioritize what's most important
even in the midst of battle gang olga
seems to be the perfect choice to mentor
the young heroes
one of the highlights of season five
this matchup gives bakugo the character
development that he's deserved for a
while
finding himself in the unlikely position
of team leader the explosive hero in
training proves everyone wrong by
excelling in this role he shows keen
intelligence the ability to come up with
smart battle tactics effectively uses
his teammate's strengths and builds a
dream team
there's still the old bar google we know
and love the one who likes to let loose
and win at all costs but imagine a
bargoogle who protects his partners and
expects them to do the same for him
this adds layers to his personality
apart from its main hero this contest
shines as a rare spotlight on some of
the series more overlooked characters
namely jiro
santo and hanta jiro especially makes an
impact with a more battle-hardy version
of her quirk earphone jack dolgage
the wily leader of the rival team from
class 1b also makes a strong impression
with a lizard-inspired quirk but at the
end of it all
this is an explosive tribute to bakugo
we've got to say
we're all loving the new and improved
gotcha
now could there be a team more
incompatible than this the rivalry
between deku and bakugo is the main
relationship
fault line in mha and this episode shows
just how deep the discord runs
at first it seems almost criminal to put
them on the same team
but this is anime and strange things can
happen forced together to fight the
number one hero the duo managed to give
their opponent a rip-roaring battle
without budging an inch from their
original positions of hostility and
distrust towards each other
at the very beginning midoriya gives up
on having any kind of meaningful
conversation with his partner
bakugo on the other hand is adamant that
he doesn't need a nerd cramping his
style
deku is all for escaping to victory
while bakuga won't hear of anything but
fighting his way through
they're completely at odds and the fight
seems like a lost cause
it's perhaps only their mutual respect
for all might that pushes them into some
kind of grudging
erratic team play miraculously though it
gets the job done
and you can't help but cheer loudly for
this odd pair
another contest between class 1a and
class 1b
makes the cut at number 7.
this fight marks shinzo's comeback after
his loss to midoriya in season two
despite having led his rival by his nose
for most of that match with his
brainwashing quirk
now back for round two both contestants
brought exciting new upgrades to their
power games
but that's not what's important about
this contest what's important
is that this clash like all the others
in season five is a celebration
of teamwork both sides show excellent
synergy and the team leaders get to
share the spotlight with their teammates
ulanaka is that pivotal character for
team midoriya she showed us what stern
stuff she's made of during her match
with barcugo in season 2
and here she proves to be the linchpin
for her team since midori is struggling
with his unstable new power
it's also a joy to watch monomer he's
competitive
sarcastic polite arrogant passive
aggressive and
cowardly but he's also loyal
entertaining and
a bit of a nut case
[Music]
team todoroki versus team tetsutetsu is
a scorcher of a clash quite literally
for each member of each team brings
their a-game
ice prince todoroki cranks up the
competition with a blistering display of
his so far neglected
firepower seeing him push to his limits
and then overcome those limits is a
testament to his raw talent
squad maida is also in full throttle as
he introduces his new move recipro turbo
which takes his speed to dizzying limit
he's still the responsible class
president prioritizing the safety of his
teammates
but he still has an eye on victory as
the pillars of the class 1a team
todoroki and eder dazzle with their
potential for more awesomeness the
battle might have ended in a draw but
it's not a disappointing result at all
rather it's the fairest result because
each contestant plays out of their skin
and there are no losers in the end
at the midway point now we have red riot
and fat gum
versus rapa and tengai this is a
breakthrough moment for kirishima
who finally lays his old doubts about
his quirked arrest with a standard
performance against
very capable enemies it's a contest in
which he truly earns his hero name
red riot hiroshima's team is at a
disadvantage right from the beginning as
rapper and tengai form the perfect spear
and shield combination with one going on
the offensive and the other providing an
indestructible defense
conquering his inner demons and firing
his self-worth several notches up
the redhead manages to reach a perfect
state of hardening and become an
unbreakable shield for his partner
fat gum sums up hiroshima's great leap
forward perfectly when he says that both
he and their opponents might have
underestimated the hero
red riot what a compliment
as a notorious hero killer stains easily
one of the most memorable antagonists of
my hero academia you might have the
numbers on your side but a single stain
can still prove to be your worst
nightmare
this is the situation an unstable eda
finds himself in when he rushes into
avengers brother who's been
attacked and maimed by stain apart from
the three versus one contest
this battle in hosu city stands out for
many firsts it's the first time we see
the rule-bound either lose his call and
act recklessly
it's a moment that will have a huge
bearing on his growth as a hero we also
see the first signs of friendship
between midoriya and todoroki
who make it just in time to rescue
either an unexpected end to the entire
episode makes this
a very gripping arc
foreign
now this clash is both kick-ass in its
action choreography as well as a sweet
story of redemption for one of the
show's most unlikable characters thus
far
so this moment endeavors a rude arrogant
and condescending jerk he's also one of
the world's worst father and husband his
treatment of todoroki and his mother is
absolutely appalling endeavour might
fight on the side of the good but he is
more villain than hero
that is tilly reminds us all with this
epic contest that while he might not be
mr popular or have the greatest smile in
the world
he's still a hero you can count on in
the worst of times in his fiery battle
against hood endeavour shows us the full
range of his supremely powerful quirk
once more he forms a great team with
hawks to put down the threat presented
by the high-end nomu
fighting his first battle as the newly
crowned number one hero endeavour proves
that he's more than worthy of inheriting
all might's title and his heavy burden
as well
[Music]
in the number two spot is midoriya and
all might versus wolfram from the 2018
movie
my hero academia two heroes needless to
say the highlight of this fight is the
coming together of mentor and protege
against a common enemy pushed to his
limits by wolfram
all might admits to midoriya that he
needs his help to bring down the last
boss
the confession is a refreshing change of
pace from traditional storylines where
the teacher stubbornly chooses to
protect their student
rather than seek their help and put them
in harm's way it also shows just how
much faith
all might has in his successor the two
race towards wolfram and soundly defeat
the metal manipulator with a double
detroit smash
and a loud holler of plus ultra this
fight's incredible in its chemistry and
choreography the fast-paced action is
some of the best we've seen in anime
there's this one
visually arresting shot of almighty
midoriya running a step apart
in which the two chillingly look alike
canon or not it's a cinematic work of
art
that shows that the power of one for all
has been successfully passed on and is
now in capable hands
[Music]
yes yeah
now this isn't the first time the
childhood rivals have teamed up as we
already know but this is perhaps the
only instance where the two willingly
put their differences aside to join
hands
quite literally the villain who forces
them into this unlikely alliance is nine
one of the most powerful antagonists in
the mha universe with his ability to
steal and use multiple quirks
all of them incredibly powerful the
action is top grade
nine reigns quirks and runs rings around
the heroes in training but a massive
twist in the tail is what powers this
clash right to the top of the heap on
the verge of defeat midoriya gets the
crazy idea of transferring one for all
to barcugo in a desperate final bid to
defeat nine
crazy right nobody saw it coming even
for a non-canon movie victory
does come at a price does deku lose his
quirk forever after having worked so
hard to earn one in the first place
does it make sense for the main
protagonist of a superhero anime to not
have a superpower anymore you'll have to
watch the movie to find out for now
let's just say midoriya and barcugo make
a heck of a team
well that's it folks what's your
favorite team fight in my hero academia
did your favorite alliance make the cut
write to me in the comments section
below and let me know if you like the
video go ahead and press that like
button you can also subscribe to my
channel vinnie tube for more action
anime and top 10 videos
special thanks to zodiac 15 and all
other patreons for making this video
possible
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video zen market see if it's
your liking and start shopping now bye
for now and i'll see you soon with a new
subject and a new video